there's a lot of pressure as far as
pressure I don't think he builds it he
certainly feels officially he wants the
ball when the game's on the line is he
the best we'll find out the thing that
separates them from him right now is
they all want to stay championship state
of mind you gotta win it off and Jarrett
is a a free player already fast and
already strong he's got all the
attributes this game is pressure mental
pressure Russian pressure Britain Russia
Belarus Russia pressure so Wednesday I
mean there's a lot of pressure with me
being one of the top quarterbacks in the
country and people think you know that
we got it in the bag we made it to the
semi-finals last year and most teams
would be thrilled with that outcome
we're just ticked off about it we expect
to get to that higher level every single
year he is everything that everyone has
tabbed him to be he is the real deal and
you can usually pick up within five
minutes two guys got it or not you know
and I watched him throw one of the balls
I'm talking about it was 40 yards on the
line
there's a guy draping his hip and he
drops it right in the bucket with no art
into a north wind it's about 30 miles an
hour you know and I was probably
thinking people don't know how hard that
throw is
when they're freshmen we're playing
Mesquite horn Jarek goes on a sweep
takes off down the sideline there's two
kids got an angle on it and he just flat
rings off and leaves we're all like whoo
and all the people from Mesquite that
were there they're all like I mean that
why keep it running he can definitely
play at the league he was effortless in
the way that he knew when to drive the
ball how to throw a whole shot he can
throw this hips open and out all that's
natural to him he's never been taught
that stuff that's stuff that I didn't
learn until I was first second third
year in the league you know and then I'd
go back and watch the film and say oh
yeah you know I had a little bit of that
Jared's got all that he's got a talent
level that I think it has no ceiling
basically it's like the movie Friday
Night Lights the town closes down last
person to leave turn the lights out
everyone else is at the game if George
did his quarterback in the state
championship team he'll be he'll be able
to be elected mayor here you might as
well roll out the red carpet he's gonna
get treated like royalty he will be
looked at like he was a Peyton Manning
Tom Brady in Stephenville Texas
the expectation is state championship
you see the signs the weights are coming
into town welcome to steam builders how
many state championships that we have
they have five turned out 12 to 13
Division One quarterbacks here in
Stephenville Texas if you want to be
considered one of the great ones you got
to go win your state championship you
better win tonight because if you don't
win state that's not a successful season
it's just just a big deal that's what a
lot of this just comes down to is just
what people expect from us you're in
you're out the main thing that makes
your it different is has nothing to do
with football he understands that the
pressure is out there
and he's got to realize that he's one of
the best there or in the in the state as
far as what he does but you would not
know it by talking to him I don't I
don't read the newspapers I don't really
read articles and I try to stay away
from all the hype and everything like
that my big thing is always you know
stay humble if I don't win the state
title here I mean I still think I would
be recognized but also I would be that
guy that couldn't you know couldn't get
the job done when it went mattered time
I mean it's our time to set the tone
like yelling dragon football and let's
head pause you understand me sir then
get yourself in the playoffs right now
grab ahold of above it holding tight
because we're going on that field of
battle
our father on the keeper around the
right side will stretch and he will make
it for the goal line touchdown
Stephenville jackets take the lead back
1310 Stidham in the pocket throws across
the middle and it is back Darion Brown
d-money was a touchdown it doesn't
matter
later and the game will come to an end
with the jackets winning over Schneider
the Matadors and the jackets get ready
for this area round playoff bats in them
now will step up into the pocket
throwing it into the back of the end
zone and is it cut it is then bust to
the outside Stidham to us gets on the
corner returns it 35 30 25 20 pulling
away
Jared's Denham the exclamation point
just about ready to get this one kicked
off bounces out to the 10 to the 5 gets
across is he there
Stephenville straight drop for Jarrett
looking throwing across the middle and
it's caught step will beat the touchdown
never bounded at 1 second to understand
the checkers are moving on to the state
quarterfinals at packed house here at
Ram Stadium
big blitz coming going across the middle
it is fun
Stephanie picks away at the bay does he
get in yes touchdown Stephenville he
will try to air this one out going for
it deep downfield and it's going to be
picked off in the end zone
Turner on the straight drop looking to
throw throwing across the middle caught
touchdown wide open was Todd Parker that
will do it as the Yellowjackets 2014
season will come to an end I lost it I
mean I I knew I wasn't ever going to
play Stephenville football again put on
the blue and gold and play with those
guys I've always grown up with you know
I hate I hate losing I really do and
definitely don't want to experience him
like that again
[Music]
as much as I hate to say it but I mean
I'll always be that guy couldn't
couldn't get the job done when it
battered
[Music]
you
[Music]